on peut le noter vous allez avoir droit
à une hardy view
tu bouges par le jingle l'argent pas
bouger bouger ou ce qu'on pourrait
rallumer s'il vous plaît de faire bouger
ya des gens qui bougent de la vie voilà
à chaud mais john gotti on va perdre une
heure dix view
bouge pas pendant les guignols caunes a
enchanté moi c'est laurent alors jean
paul gaultier où se concentrent vous
pensez à quoi là maintenant présentement
à la question que vous êtes en train de
me poser voilà quand vous regardez la
glace le matin vous dites quoi t'as
d'beaux yeux tu sais ce que je me dis
ouais quand vous étiez petit vous dire
semblait acquis saturne savez le canard
le décanat à tous explique ici comment
s'expliquent tout est clair ce soir
quand avez vous pleuré pour la dernière
fois est bon ou du filet de saint orens
justement quel est le péché qui vous
tant que plus la gourmandise
que pourriez-vous dire de plus négatif
sur vous non merci
si votre vie était à refaire que
changeriez vous rien qui avez vous le
plus envie d'épater madame pompidou
ouais on va dire que c'est moi même
quand téléphone sonne il est heureux ou
agacé ben ça dépend ça dépend si c'est
ça dépend si c'est le téléphone privé ou
du coeur ou comme ça la ligne
ce que tout le monde appelle les ninjas
coeur et oui j'aime bien d'ailleurs la
zone euro va s'inscrire et vous devrez
vous donnerai
jt c'est génial que feriez vous s'il
vous restait 24 heures à vivre je ferai
une orgie de pouffer de sexe allez va
très bien il vous quel est le surnom
qu'on vous donne que vous haïssez
l'enfant terrible de la mode sont
maintenant quand même un peu vieilli
l'enfant terrible c'est resté quand même
dans ces régions en détresse est très
beau mais quand même non mentalement et
moralement
et dieu dans tout ça que son coin c'est
vrai c'est ma chance est ce pour cela le
dieu il faut qu'ils s'habillent coutu
non non vous êtes marrant parce qu'on
fait du sampling même pour la religion
puisque vous les religions étaient très
sain critiques c'est à dire vous dites
on prendra un petit peu chez le cateau
un petit peu chez juif je vois que plein
de choses
nous avons toutes les religions est-ce
que vous organiserez un dîner où l'on ne
parle pas de vous ben oui comme ça je
pourrai manger à qu'avez-vous fait que
nous ne sachions pas j'aime bien faire
quelquefois des plaisanteries dans les
hôtels par exemple vous savez il ya
toujours les cartes là de petits
déjeuners et tout alors j'aime bien
changer leurs mets toi plutôt genre 4
heures du matin et ubl ce moment tu
avais dit des normes des harengs changé
et vous changer les choses si ces
échanges et le chaudron le talon
aiguille là où on sait qu'un monsieur
aulas très bon voilà qu'est ce que vous
avez dans vos poches la préservatif de
quelle question à me riez vous avoir la
réponse il existe tout un miroir mon
beau miroir qui est la plus belle à
billets et ce soir dakar qu'est ce que
la vie nous a appris qu'on pouvait faire
ce qu'on rêve si on est passionné voilà
vous faire tout ce qu'on rêve lorsqu'on
veut ouais avez vous une meilleure
opinion de vous aujourd'hui qu'à 20 ans
je crois je me sens mieux dans ma peau
ça sonne ce oui à quels signes
reconnaissez-vous infailliblement la
bêtise c'est difficile à dire parce que
moi j'en dis pas mal de sottises m'enfin
je sais pas ce qui me ferait un peu
c'est les gens qui sont très sûrs d'eux
et qu'ils croient connaître la réponse à
tout une autre était ce bien mais c'est
pas toutes les réponses
quel est votre expression favorite vain
dieu amon ouais c'est un génie ou venez
vous proposez d'exaucer de vos souhaits
qu'elle soit vous feriez ce serait de
ressusciter les personnes qui sont
montées que j'aime
voilà quelle est l'insulté qui lui a
fait le plus mal [ __ ]
à gervinho